the idea that when things go wrong it's
not a problem
you embrace failure and you look for the
lesson and always trying to
take from the experience doesn't matter
what happens to you it's
it's what lesson you can take from it
benjamin welcome to the show hi chris
great to be here thanks for having me on
it's an uncomfortable day right we're
both sweltering we're both too hot
yeah absolutely but we've got to embrace
it well that's the lesson the lesson
that we're going to learn today so you
decided to spend a year doing a bunch of
challenges
physical stuff and mental stuff and
social stuff
what was the impetus why bother putting
yourself through hell for a year
so all of this came off the back of
anxiety actually so that was the the
trigger
for me to get into uh challenging myself
i was hit with this severe anxiety and i
started reading about all of these
things that i could do to handle that
how i could manage it
and i came across a lot of different
philosophy and psychology
and one of the things that really caught
my attention was the idea of
deliberately stepping outside of your
comfort zone
it felt very counterintuitive at the
time to be doing something like that
um but by doing that it helped me to
gain confidence and to actually
understand myself better and to
to build a bit of resilience which is
something that i was lacking because i
had no
sense of how to deal with this uh this
anxiety what's a panic attack feel like
uh well if you don't know what one is it
feels like you're dying to be honest
the first time that i had that panic
attack it was uh
it was just insane i had i had no sense
of
uh that my mental health could cause
such physical symptoms
so i imagine let me compare it to if we
were to go skydiving together
we would probably have very physical
symptoms within our bodies like
shaky hands you'd probably feel a bit
sick you'd feel scared
um you know you would feel this nausea
and this sense of fear
but that's pretty normal because that's
something you know there's a reason for
that
now imagine not having a trigger or a
reason and you just have those
those sensations all the time 24 7. it's
hard to sleep it's hard to eat
and that's basically what an anxiety
disorder becomes
uh so it's very hard to to function as a
normal human being so this was a trigger
that started this this whole journey and
got me into writing got me into
stoicism buddhism and all these
different philosophies and actually
encouraged me to start challenging
myself have you got any idea what
caused you to get into this spiral of
anxiety and panic attacks and stuff in
the first instance
it was there some sort of a trigger is
it like a compounding effect of just
general ambient anxiety and malaise
i think there wasn't actually a trigger
as such it was i think
it was more of a compounding thing i
think it's not being able to understand
my mind
very well i didn't understand mental
health and it was just the cumulative
stress and
it was just the not being able to handle
difficulty and i just had this internal
dialogue that wasn't really helping me
and would just make things a lot worse
by um
spiraling things out of control so there
wasn't a clear trigger there wasn't like
an event that caused it to happen it was
just uh
it just came out of the blue which i
guess is even more brutal
right when you don't know you can't draw
the line from
cause and effect you're actually like oh
hang on like am i dying
like i actually might be dying yeah um
yeah so i had
james nestor on the podcast yesterday
guy that wrote breath
and um he's talking about the two
main functions that you do with breath
work right so one of them is an extreme
activation of the sympathetic nervous
system it's the wim hof it's a
it's that [ __ ] and then the other is an
extreme activation of the
parasympathetic nervous system it's
dialing yourself down to
in three breaths a minute two breaths a
minute uh it's extreme holds at the end
it's free diving holding your breath for
a long time stuff like that
and um what i had in my head while he
was talking about it and this will
that episode will be out so everyone
will know what i'm talking about even
though you don't um
you know the the concept of an overton
window right like which is
um a bound of acceptable speech within
so you can imagine that you've got all
of the speech that you could do on a
little spectrum from 0 to 100 and then
you have the overton window with
which is what's acceptable in normal
society and people won't look at you
like you're a weirdo or some sort of
like
crazy person if you say and that's maybe
let's say from 25 to 75
so you can still say things that are out
on the ends but those things are likely
to get you into trouble and to cause you
problems
and what james was talking about was
that a lot of the time
we exist in a increasingly narrower and
narrower band
of this sympathetic to parasympathetic
situation
we're going from perhaps 40 to 60 or
from
you know like 30 to 70 something like
that and
when you do get knocked out into one of
those you have to give a presentation at
work
or you have to have an awkward
conversation with your spouse or
you're sat on your own in a room for you
know the other end of the scale you just
sat bored and your phone's died at a
train station and you're driving
yourself crazy because you can't bear to
live with
how much relaxation you're going through
um
that's where the issues arise
for people and breath was his focus so
he was saying look by doing this
extreme sympathetic and parasympathetic
activation you're actually starting to
pull that window back out like look
it's okay to be in this situation
because our ancestors would have run for
ages and chased something down and then
they'd have sat around for ages
and done absolutely nothing and we kind
of just exist slap bang in the middle
not going to either of the extremes well
i think the thing is we're not taught
this kind of stuff
it's uh i certainly wasn't taught this
at school it wasn't something that i was
aware of
and um i think it's it's something that
is incredibly important this education
how do you deal with something when it
comes along how do you deal with anxiety
or how do you
how do you change how do you create
change in your life and i i think that
educating
yourself and getting into that is
extremely important
and that's the great thing about what so
many people are doing with their
podcasts and what you're doing with your
podcast as well you're helping people to
be exposed to these ideas
that can ultimately change their lives
and that's something
i loved his book i loved the breath i
thought that was fantastic
and i think it would have been really
helpful actually for me
to have uh to put two and two together
to have got the
the sense of what you can do just from
the power of breathing as well i think
um it would have been helpful at the
time think about
talking about the learning thing like
that's the same as well you have this
band of people that you typically see
who all have
relatively similar world views and even
if they have different world views after
enough time you've heard all of their
world views
like it is without exposing yourself to
books and podcasts and youtube and
whatever else it might be traveling you
are stuck
hearing the same rhetoric and the same
narrative over and over you're not going
to learn that many things but you're
totally right the ability for people to
consume as much as they want from
wherever they want and
you know i think the job of a podcaster
as at least the type of podcast that i
try to create is
to be more like a museum curator
than anything else so what you hope when
you go into a museum or an art gallery
or something
you know that maybe not every single
piece of art is going to be like wow i'm
in i'm in love with that
but you have faith that the curator has
been able to put together an experience
which overall you're going to
see new things and get exposed to stuff
that you hadn't seen before and then
maybe get exposed to stuff that you
already love but
you see it in a new way or whatever it
is and that's how it kind of feels to me
but
again pulling people outside of that
overton window like speaking to a porn
star
and a philosopher in the space of a week
or doing something like that so
yeah that's the uh get your ears
comfortable at being uncomfortable
perhaps that that might be the
equivalent all right so you so you
go through this stuff you're struggling
mental health what do you start to
resonate with first what's the first
thing that you read where you're like
okay there's something to this
so i started reading a lot of different
things and
it became a bit of a quest to try and
figure out what i can do and
actually i really like connected to a
load of different ideas but i have to
say the one that
made the biggest difference in my life
was stoicism and
i kind of i got into that because it
caught me with this concept voluntary
discomfort
and i love how the stoics were so
creative in the ways that they would
push themselves out of their comfort
zone so they would sleep on the floor uh
they would expose themselves to the cold
and the heat
they would fast from food and water and
there was a stoic uh called cato who
would deliberately wear things
to feel shame so he could practice
feeling like an idiot what like
and so he would i mean back in the day
it would have just been a different
colored cloak or something like that and
we can play with that today but i just
love the idea
it's so counterintuitive this this
concept of someone
deliberately seeking out um attention
like that and not in a way
it's not attention-seeking but it's to
to get that
feeling of self-consciousness and being
able to work with it and understand it
and
and not be worried about how people are
judging you
and this this just caught my attention i
fell in love with this idea
and this is really why i started
challenging myself
and i started off with very small
challenges um the first one was actually
walking to the local bench which was
only about 100 meters away
but that should give you an idea of how
like what a dark mental space i was in
um but over time it compounded and i
started
to get more confident and ended up doing
bigger and bolder things and and some of
them were very stoic
so things like sleeping on the floor
that's a great one
and that's something that everyone can
try it's not easy no mattress nothing
just sleep next to your bed
and that's that's very very hard to do
but it's a mindset thing
so i love this concept from stoicism and
that got me into it and then i just
you know explored the philosophy more
and now it's just something that helps
me
every day i think kato practiced
walking backward through a crowd that
was leaving a theater did you see this
one
yeah i've heard i i've i've heard the
cynics as well
the cynic philosophers inspired the
stoics and um this kind of
someone described them as the trolls of
ancient greece which i think is
a great way great way to discuss this
this type of philosophy
diogenes was absolutely a troll man that
wasn't it so alexander they're great for
anyone that doesn't know this
sort of the diogenes story diogenes is
this
guy in ancient greece i want to say and
he lives in a pot which is literally the
thing that you piss
and [ __ ] in and he lives in that he
wears a
like an old rice sack rag thing that's
his clothing
and but he's walking around and telling
people
good philosophy insights and stuff like
that so alexander the great he is of him
and he arrives in greece and he finds
him just bathing in the sun
and he walks up to him and he says
diogenes i've heard that you're an
incredible man
uh tell me what you would wish for and
if it is within my power i will give it
to you
and diogenes said i would wish for you
to get out of my sunlight
and just shift it alex under the great
otherwise that kind of tells you
it tells you all you really need to know
yeah he absolutely was he was like the
loki
the loki of ancient greece i suppose but
um
yes fascinating man i mean wearing itchy
clothing they used to do
walking around barefoot purposefully
dropping things wasn't it
didn't zeno used to push his disciples
when they were carrying
food and drinks and stuff so they'd
accidentally drop
vases of wine and everyone would turn
around and look at them or he'd spill
he'd spill stuff on them so they'd have
to walk around with like wine stains on
them
so all of this what people are trying to
do is learn that the level of discomfort
that you go through
isn't a mortal threat that's what you're
trying to do because it feels so
overwhelming right it feels
oh my god the phenomenology of this
crazy set of hormones
rushing through my body is terrifying
and my heart rate's high and i'm
sweating and i've got clammy hands and i
my vision's all blurred but it's fine
it's just okay and that voluntary
exposure i think is
is what you're trying to get at there
yeah absolutely it's such a beautiful
concept and
i think it's what i find so appealing
about it is it's like a combination of
fear and play which are two things that
don't really go hand in hand
and uh i i love this concept so there's
something that i would love to
contribute to stoicism
and it's it's kind of an extension of
this and it's it's called the
anti-bucket list and it's basically
this thing it's like fear exposure so we
know a bucket list is it's a list of
things we want to do before we die
the anti-bucket list is things that we
don't want to do before we die and we
can easily avoid them
being adults we don't have to push
ourselves out of our comfort zone
so i love this idea you collect things
that scare you and you create your list
your anti-bucket list
and then you deliberately go out and you
do that and that is a very stoic thing
i'll give you an example for me i had a
massive fear of needles i mean i had a
fear of a lot of things but
needles was one of the things that just
really really got me
so that was on my anti-bucket list so i
turned that into a challenge
and went and had acupuncture which is
the most extreme
version of having to deal with needles
when you get them in your face and
you're
you're all over your body so that
it feels counter intuitive and it's it's
scary but actually the growth that you
experience
when you push yourself out of your
comfort zone like that when you use fear
as
something to play around with it's it's
an amazing
amazing thing that can happen to you and
it can help build confidence and
and ultimately resilience as well so i
love this concept and i think the stoics
just
you know really started off something
wonderful with with this idea
what's on the anti-bucket list that you
haven't done yet
oh it's uh i'm giving blood that's
that's the next one
oh that's needles that's serious needles
yeah and for some people that's not
that's no
no bother for them you know a lot of
people will listen to this and say oh
that that's
that's ridiculous it's very easy but if
you've got a it's blood as well it's not
just the needle it's the needle and the
blood so
um that's that's the next big one uh i'm
like i'm looking forward to it actually
it's going to be one of those uh
those things that i kind of don't want
to do it but that's the point
so i'm looking forward to the growth
that i'll experience and
probably very sweaty palms as well but i
think it would be
for me it would be spiders snakes stuff
like i'm not i'm just not not my bag and
you're totally right as well
with the anti-bucket list i could spend
the entire easily easily spend the rest
of my life never exposing myself to
snakes and spiders other than
on the other side of some glass
somewhere uh yeah
and i've got something very wrong if i
accidentally have to pick up a snake or
a spider there's something very
in fact i've probably got more to worry
about than the snake or the spider if i
need to do that all right so you start
off with with stoicism what else did you
study that you thought gave you a good
impact um so i loved buddhism as well
buddhism was very helpful
and there's lots of ideas interestingly
stoicism and buddhism there's a real
crossover
there's a lot of ideas that balance and
they
kind of look similar even though they
were created
thousands of miles apart so i think
that's quite interesting that they came
to this
conclusion so there's a focus on being
present
um and actually living in the moment
which is something that
both the stoics and the buddhists talk a
lot a lot about
and gratitude building a sense of
gratitude into
everything that you do and they came
about it from different ways
so in buddhism there's this thing called
the loving kindness meditation where you
think well of someone and
you uh even people that you struggle
with challenging people
you wish them well which can feel again
counterintuitive but
this is to help you i guess
develop empathy and to help you to
to explore compassion in an interesting
way
the stoic way of doing this was
through negative visualization so they
would picture things
um being taken away from them so they
contemplate loss as a way to
um increase their gratitude so although
they're two different
approaches there's a similarity there
there's a developing gratitude and a
deeper sense of gratitude
um so yeah there's lots of crossovers
but i i really liked
some of the ideas in buddhism mainly the
philosophical buddhism
rather than the religious side of things
there because obviously
buddhism has developed into lots of
different types of um
it's got loads of different schools and
different branches and
i think some of them are
very ritual heavy and the very
um well there's certain ideas and
certain rituals that
aren't necessarily going to help me but
i like going back to the actual core
philosophy
and some of the ideas that uh that's
behind
buddhism is is very very helpful the
idea of
impermanence is is a great one as well
how did that help
so the idea of impermanence is is that
everything changes
so when you're in a terrible situation
you focus on the fact that it will
change
and this is perfect for dealing with a
panic attack because
when you're caught up in panic you think
that's it
it's you're just here but remembering
that everything moves and evolves and
changes
is something that can really help you
and it can help with doing difficult
challenges as well
when you're in a scary situation
focusing on the fact that
it's going to change is is very powerful
and again this is also
an idea in stoicism um the impermanence
and so it's lovely how they connect and
and i think uh it's very practical
one of the main insights about uh why
people commit suicide
that i learned was that lack of an
understanding of impermanence
it's a bunch of different prerequisites
and the final one is
and it's not going to get any better so
that's it it's the fact that
this moment for now is going to stretch
for eternity i've had
friends who have been weaning off
different types of medication and all
sorts of different things
and in the moment one of the things that
you're desperately trying to tell them
is look like
i know that it's uncomfortable now but
it it will get better it will get better
it will get better
and yeah keeping that in mind uh that's
an important one you looked at
carol dweck's mindset as well right and
he did some cbt stuff too
yes yes mindset is one of my favorite
books of all time
i think it's an unbelievably useful
concept
the idea that there's a growth mindset
and a fixed mindset
and i could see when i was in peak
anxiety i was very very fixed mindset on
so many things
and the growth mindset is this openness
to
new ideas and the ability to
step outside your comfort zone i guess
you could think of it like that
the idea that you
when things go wrong it's not a problem
you embrace
failure and you look for the lesson and
always trying to
take from the experience doesn't matter
what happens to you it's
it's what lesson you can take from it so
i think that's a that's again a very
powerful thing and
throughout all of these challenges that
i started doing um
having this in the back of my mind this
growth mindset
the ability to look for the lesson to
always look for the lesson was uh
something that i kept coming back to and
it's very very helpful
well it reminds you as well the this
won't last forever that's
impermanent right here's a lesson it's
i'm not in a fixed mindset it also helps
you to
dissolve the ego away look i i failed
but that's not
really a comment on me as a human it
doesn't
change the person that i am or all of
the things that i've done it's just
just a failure like what's the lesson
from it move on so yeah
again mindset i think coalesces nicely
with the buddhism and the stoicism
then what about cbt because i know cbt
like some of the principles and stuff
come out
come out of stoicism what was this
specifically from cbt that you hadn't
got
from anything else so i think it was
mainly just being conscious of my
internal dialogue this is the great
thing about cbt it really gets you
to question the way that you're talking
to yourself internally
uh and during peak anxiety again
negative
like frame of mind very fixed mindset
and the way that i would talk to myself
in my head was
unhelpful very very unhelpful so i think
being conscious of that is the first
step
to to be able to change it when you're
aware of something you can then
act and you can try and change it so the
the cbt kind of golden rule is that you
blast
your negative thoughts with logic and
you use
logic to destroy the uh the negative
dialogue
and you might have to work really hard
and it's not always going to be natural
to start off with but the more you do it
the more natural it becomes and then you
kind of automatically start doing that
in your head i mean i'm not perfect but
i'm getting better at it and it has
certainly helped me
to manage that anxiety what was the best
cbt book that you read
or some of them um
the best one i read it was it was
actually like
the um the cbd
um cbt for dummies that kind of really
base levels yeah yeah one of those i
can't
remember the exact title and i can't
remember the author so i don't want to
um i don't want to say because i
obviously i like to be able to say what
the author's name is
because i feel that do the the book
justice but
um yeah i think it was it was just uh
one of those
sort of introductory books um it wasn't
it wasn't a particular one it feels to
me like
because at the moment we've had like pop
psychology has been kicking off and
stoicism's kicking off and buddhism is
kicking off and stuff at the moment in
the
intellectual awakening world i haven't
really seen someone popularize cbt i
don't know whether
maybe stoicism and buddhism and pop
psychology are
taking so many chunks out of the
insights that you would get from cbt
that someone doesn't think it's
worthwhile
to put a cbt book out there but
certainly the the
relationship that we have with our inner
monologue the blasting our thoughts with
logic
some of the insights from cbt i
personally i think haven't been
popularized as well as they should have
been yet there hasn't been a scientific
communicator or a research communicator
or just a
you know anyone an author that's come
out and really being like look
here's the too long didn't read of
35 years of cbt research
no it's so interesting and i definitely
think it should be taught in schools as
well
it's something that would make a huge
difference to the next generation
i think so many mental health problems
would be alleviated
uh almost preemptively solved if we were
teaching things like that in school
teaching children how to have a that
narrative inside their head and how to
manage these things when they crop up so
yeah i'd love to see i'd love to see
more of that
i think a buddy is in america and his
kids go to a school
and he was telling me that the teacher
um teaches them to name their emotions
and and give them different colors like
it's like the the pirate is is angry and
there's something like the hippo is
happy and so i can't remember i'm
butchering it again
but um yeah they are they're trying to
step into your own programming
and to just notice look there is
something that's captured you there is a
sensation that's inside of you just sit
and name it and obviously they've had to
kidify it up and
make it about like whatever hippos and
pirates and stuff like that but
yeah you're right i mean think about
most of the people that are listening to
this
the adults that have been adults for a
significantly longer time than they've
been intellectually awakened and
on this path of trying to become better
humans imagine if
you didn't have to undo well imagine if
you were starting even if you're just
starting from zero not like minus one
thousand three hundred
like it would be so much it'll be so
much easier
yeah absolutely of course and that's why
i think getting
these ideas into schools would be just
just brilliant um things like meditation
as well i think that's that's so
important that's been very helpful for
me
uh and that ties in with a lot of these
other ideas
all right so you do these you did
hundreds and hundreds of challenges and
then you sort of listed
43 in the book what was the second one
after going to the bench can you
remember second one was going um
catching a bus
so it's a little bit of an upgrade from
walking to the bench moving but then
yeah and then then it compounded and
then
then it just started getting you know
more confident and
bigger and bolder things followed what
about that welsh train station you learn
the name of the the longest word
in the world it's the longest train
station
in the world yes uh
now i've probably done a terrible job of
that and if anyone in welsh is listening
they're gonna say that was
that was a horrible rendition of it but
it was a very small challenge
but i just love the fact that it's
something new it's something novel
and challenges can be found in many
different places
and they don't always have to be epic so
some of my challenges were very big
running a marathon and climbing
mountains learning japanese
but some were small like that one is the
perfect example of the small challenge
and it's a great one as well it's fun
it's uh it's a good one to learn
all right and then you should learn it
yeah well i'll replay that i'll just
go to sleep listening to you going
um talking to a stranger on the streets
i think
um most people tend to have
capacities within certain domains that
all
line up so someone might be very good
physically at putting themselves into
you know like a zone four zone five
heart rate but then
if you tell them to do something
socially they might struggle someone
that social might really struggle to
make themselves
go into the discomfort of learning and
memorization or something like that
out of the sort of broad buckets of
challenges was there one that you were
like look
this continues to come i i find social
situations significantly more difficult
i find
physical situations significantly more
difficult was there something that you
discovered there um i think that all of
the challenges present
unique insights into how my mind works
um i certainly find that well i'm an
introvert so
for me putting a stupid hat on and
walking down a busy high street
is it feels maybe maybe you'll be harder
um i don't have it to hand actually i
wish i could show you but um i've got
this crab hat i bought it in japan and
it is literally a crab
that goes around your face like this and
it's got little claws
and it's it's very very ridiculous um
so if you wear something like that it's
people will look at you
and that's fine but it's just dealing
with that
um as an extrovert you probably i've got
a friend who
i've seen him dance naked on a table in
front of thousands of people at a
festival
he's not supposed to be on the table
this is just it's just a festival
and he loved the attention he loved
having people look at him
so for him putting a crab hat on and
walking down a busy street he's going to
love him he just what he wants
for fun yeah exactly so it's it's
playing around with the things that you
personally find
challenging so for an extrovert maybe it
would be the opposite so
going on a silent retreat or cutting
yourself off from that
um and just exploring the introverted
side because we've all got a mix of
introversion and extroversion um but i
think
it's nice to explore how that
relates to us as individuals and and to
play around with both sides of it
weren't you getting naked at some point
as well didn't you do it like a naked
challenge
that was one of the worst that like as
in i didn't really do a great job of
that i talked about it in the book but
yeah that was uh
um a nudist speech for a very short
amount of time
how do you not do a good job of being
naked um because
you feel so paranoid um and i think
just the internal dialogue wasn't great
and i was just very self-conscious and
um i didn't spend a long time naked so
that's that's how i did a bad job for it
are you familiar with the 100 days of
rejection therapy challenge
did you look at this um i've heard about
rejection therapy
um which is i like that where you
deliberately
do things that people are going to say
no to or you might if they say yes you
might end up with a very funny story
like trying to order a square pizza or
trying to do that kind of stuff yeah i
love that idea
people should go and check that out if
you're bored and a new phone at the
moment just google 100 days of rejection
therapy challenge
and it's it's exactly what it says it's
100 days of rejection like you go to a
stranger and ask them for 100 pounds
like just random random random stupid
stuff
and that's exactly the same i'm sure
that the the principle
that you're trying to learn is exactly
the same as you it's obviously very
focused on the social side
overcoming social anxiety overcoming the
fear of other people thinking that
you're dumb or
or rejection specifically i suppose um
but yeah and then you worked on
summoning adrenaline as well obviously a
lot of the things that you did
gave you adrenaline but i suppose as
someone that was suffering with panic
attacks and
a little bit of social anxiety as well
actually
working on getting that adrenaline
pushing that parasympathetic system as
we were talking about how did you do
that how do you summon adrenaline
so you basically do stuff that scares
the living daylights out of you
and that's going to be different for
everyone for me i
did a lot of climbing and pushed myself
with climbing
and that's very very physical and mental
at the same time so if you're climbing a
scary route you're going to have a lot
of adrenaline
in your body and just learning how to
manage that learning how to be okay with
having adrenaline in your body because
actually
that feeling is very similar to a panic
attack so
learning how to be okay with having
adrenaline
is essentially learning how to manage
almost
anxiety as well and so i did lots of
things client i really pushed my
climbing and
what was it what was the scariest route
that you climbed or the scariest
mountain that you went up
so i mean it's hard to say because there
was a lot of stuff i did a route in
winter
in wales with um that was just so
intense
uh it was completely frozen and it was
it was like a technical rock climb
um but very icy and it was very scary
uh so managing that with my friend as
well we we
maybe threw ourselves in a little too
deep and other other things
deep water soloing is a great example of
this where you climb above the water
and if you fall off you fall into the
sea so
i mean you can imagine you've got the
waves like bellowing around and it's
very atmospheric and it's
uh you can feel it adrenaline in your
chest and you really don't want to fall
off and you're just desperately making
sure that you don't and then you fall
off and it's fine and
you have this release of endorphins and
you prove to yourself that you can
you can do something very scary and and
the growth as well that comes with that
uh it's addictive i went to the
united states outdoor
white water training facility a couple
of years ago
and they have um a huge climbing wall
over a 10 meter pool
uh so this is the artificial climbing
and there's some that are easy and some
they've got overhangs and
you have special shoes on and that's
it's just you just do
endless rounds just constantly climbing
up and there is there's a point where
you get to
it's a battle between trying to keep
your focus on what you're doing and not
think about how high you are
away from the water and then obviously
as you get higher up
the difficulty increases but so does the
anxiety and the distraction of you
thinking about
being below if anybody has the
opportunity it was in
charlotte it was near lake norman in
charlotte so if anyone's in america
listening to this you should go
totally go and do it it's insane um but
yeah it was it was so weird
being you can get up to 10 meters
high and that you're on an overhang and
you can be hanging on with like one hand
and one foot and you're thinking right
okay so where where's the next handheld
where am i going to go from here
and be completely unstrapped
and fall and it'd be fine it was mad
experience
always so it's all about the head the
head game there really when you
you're right as soon as you're above a
certain height you really don't want to
fall
there's an invisible line there's a line
that you get to and then you're not
right okay
my bum hole is puckering hard
i think 10 meters is probably the that
point if you start going over 10 meters
i mean you should watch
i don't know if um you've seen there's
there's some amazing climbers out there
there's a guy
um who does a lot of this deep water
soloing called chris sharma
and he's a pioneer in in this uh this
kind of niche
type of climbing and some of the routes
he does is
they're just insane you look at them and
you just think this is this is
unbelievable mental control um not not
only is it technical climbing but he's
like 20 meters up and you've got to be
very careful how you land
in the water because you can really
really hurt yourself
um so yeah i like it it's an interesting
sport
you don't have to be extreme you can
just dip your toe in a little bit
you can get pretty scary at three meters
away from the water yeah you don't need
to be you don't need to be that high up
so you did um
you waited in a queue that you didn't
need to do and i'm a club promoter
so for me i'm like a cue aficionado so i
want to know all about your queue
so the cue the queueing one everyone
loves this it's because it's ridiculous
and i i love the novel and
crazy ideas and some of the challenges
that i started doing were based on
on these ideas so cue unnecessarily and
there's multiple ways you can do this
you can queue in a car which is horrible
um especially
like we all have to put up with traffic
but when you
deliberately seek it out that's when
it becomes a different thing and you've
got internal traffic
it's very very simple rush hour and then
m25 or wherever you are you just fight
you just know where it's going to be
busy and you just go
and you commit to it and it's it's very
it's that dialogue that you're having
with yourself like why am i doing this
what's the point in this is and
actually even that in itself just
working with that dialogue
it's a very practical way to test out
whether the philosophy and ideas that
you use in your life work and i
a lot of these challenges are all about
that testing out the ideas
in a very practical way so your queueing
is is
a perfect example and any tourist
attraction you just go and
cue at the end and then when you're done
cueing just leave don't go in
don't reward yourself if you reward
yourself at the end of the queue then
you validate
the queue and you don't want to do that
you want to just go away because then
that
makes it the challenge i always remember
thinking
in freshers week when we were waiting in
queues before i was the guy that
controls the queues i was the guy that
was waiting in the queues i haven't
queued since like 2007. i don't intend
on starting again but
um yeah i always remember thinking that
i could imagine there was like a queue
appreciation society and they'd wait in
a queue for ages and then at the end
they'd all like high five like yeah
that was it let's go again and i can
just go back to the back of the queue
and start again decide to go off
um you said about sleeping on the floor
what did your missus think about the
fact that you were
like like the dog basically like just
deciding to
curl up on the floor she's got used to
me doing ridiculous things now so
it's uh it's it's not that unusual
um yeah she the thing is
she's my wife is very stoic
um which is amazing but she's she's been
such a
a rock for me and she just does all this
stuff naturally she's like
she it's it's so funny um she
she thinks like a stoic without
having studied this yeah she just does
it it's just natural for her the way
that her brain works
so she doesn't need to work so hard to
to kind of put these ideas into practice
and put them into place in her life
whereas i have to
actively seek out things to to make sure
that i'm i'm keeping on top of my game
um so yeah i mean she's just she's fine
with it now she just
doesn't bat an eyelid mentally what was
the
what was the most challenging one that
you did sort of cognitively
um in terms of fear-based or in terms of
like
skill-based skill-based yeah it's still
ongoing
it's learning japanese hands-down it's a
ridiculous challenge
um it's such a hard language and it's
relentless
when you think you've uh well i mean you
do make progress
and but then when when you get to that
level then suddenly it just unlocks a
whole
another world of pain and it's a
it's a great experience because i've
never been able to speak another
language
and now all my japanese lessons are
entirely in japanese
which that is a huge confidence booster
for me to
lean into something difficult and to see
that i can do that when my
initially i didn't think for one minute
i'll be able to do it so it's that
dialogue that i i really love to
challenge
by pushing myself because
when you think you can't do something
and you prove to yourself that you can
that is a very powerful thing
um so that's what japanese has been been
able to communicate
and before the pandemic i found myself
in japan
in this bar and this geisha and these
two businessmen came in
and the the guy who was behind the bar
started playing
uh the oboe and he started playing moon
river on the oboe
and it was just this very bizarre
experience but because we were all
communicating in japanese i was like
just had to sort of take a step back and
think what is what was happening
here or something yeah exactly what's
going on but
i think that as soon as we start seeking
out challenges as soon as we start doing
stuff like this
we invite that kind of novelty into our
lives and
we bring color into into everyday life
and
that's exciting it's a really good word
to use so novelty
and intensity are the two main drivers
of memory formation so when
people say that life is getting quicker
they don't mean that life is at time is
moving
more quickly like it's times
relativistic it will always move at the
same pace
it's the same ticking clock that it was
when you were two or that when you were
40 or that when you were dying and
it's the same one that elon musk's got
like you have the same number of hours
in the day as beyonce or whatever
um but what people mean when they
actually say
time is moving faster is my impression
of time is moving quicker
and again because you only ever
experience time in the moment so when
you're talking about look at how fast
time is moving you actually mean
look at how fast time moved so it's
always a retrospective you're always
talking about
i can't remember where the time went
there is a month
or a year or a couple of years and to me
it doesn't feel like that much time
elapsed i was really interested in this
i wanted to find out
what the function is that's causing
people to feel this way and there's a
bunch of different theories and one of
them's to do with
um the like proportionality theory which
i i think is total bollocks it's that
basically
when you've been around for 40 years
each day is only this amount of 40 years
but like
you don't think about your whole life in
one go you can focus
in on months so i didn't think it was to
do with that and then i had this woman
on the show called laura vandecam
and she wrote she's a time management
expert and she
learned that one of the key drivers of
memory formation to create memory blocks
is novelty and intensity
and it's one of the reasons why when you
go away on holiday you can
remember insane stuff so i remember i
went away to africa
and i can recall the type of shoes
and the sound of the shoes and the book
and the way that the man held
the book that walked us from reception
to the boat
like the day that i arrived and yet i
couldn't tell you what i had for dinner
last night
like if you held a gun to my head right
now i have no idea what i had for dinner
last night
or what side of the bed i woke up on
this morning
but i can tell you i can tell you reece
wasn't wasn't his actual name but i
think he adopted
um i can tell you reese's shoes and the
way that he walked and the sound of it
and the smell and everything
novelty and intensity so you must
looking back
do you see that within this year does it
feel like
a very expanded sensation of time
the the period that you were doing these
challenges in
i think so the thing is that i've
carried on doing it i've carried on
seeking out novelty and initially this
was a i called it a year of adversity
because it was like i'm going to test
this idea out
of deliberately seeking discomfort
stepping outside of my comfort zone i'll
try it
for a year why not and i guess i tried
it for a couple of months and because i
could see that it was
actually really helping me i carried on
and after a year i kind of i
achieved a lot and it had really changed
my
outlook on life but it's now something
that i continue to do and there are
some challenges that are ongoing and i'm
always seeking out new things
but the novelty factor is is something
that
i think it does make it more memorable
but for me it just brings in that
that element of color like when i was in
my very anxious space
life was very black and white and
everything is scary but when you have
this introduction of novelty and
all of these kind of things it brings
color and
it just makes life exciting and it seems
more of an adventure than
something that's out there to be you
know scary the scary world
it's it's a the adventure that could
happen so i think it's just a
shift shifting mindset what's the thing
that you did with
everest and the marathon last year
so that was uh that was really fun that
was to continue
pushing myself that was during lockdown
um
i decided that i would climb mount
everest on my stairs
so i basically did 2137 reps
up and down and that's the equivalent
height of mount everest
and it was my wife was working at the
table
and i'm just like next to her just going
up and down the stairs constantly
and it was hard it was a hard challenge
it's very boring
and but it was the novelty of it
is something that i will look back on in
lockdown and i will think well that was
that was a bizarre experience and i
wrote about it for the british
mountaineering council and on the last
day i dressed up in all my
mountaineering kits and
just had a lot of fun doing it do you
know you're inside out now as well
oh yeah a little bit more creaky than
before i was gonna say yeah
like that's a lot of repetitions that's
more than you'll have done in the house
previously
it do you know what i worked out it's
probably about a year's worth of um
like stair usage i guess you've got
you've got a lot of time to do done
mental arithmetic when you're spending
two
thousand flights to go up and down how
many days or how long did this take you
so it was about 21 hours in total and i
think i did it over
eight days maybe um so i broke it broke
it down into chunks
and it was just the monotony of it it
was very interesting i ended up with
some virtual climbing partners as well
some people different people because i
was talking about it on instagram and
loads of other people started joining in
as well which is which is something
that it just brought a little bit of fun
and novelty to that
actually very difficult time when
everyone was in lockdown you couldn't do
anything and
there were lots of restrictions um so
that was really fun
another variation was not variation but
um i ran a marathon in my garden and my
garden is tiny
seven meters um it was like seven or
eight meters
um so i had to do like four thousand
lengths to actually
hit the marathon like the distance so
again
that's just bizarre i remember i was
like eight hours it was so because you
can't actually run you run
you just run and then you have to turn
and my neighbors just
they think i'm insane we had there was a
they've got kids next door and they were
just holding like signs over the fence
um to encourage me which is lovely but
they just think i'm mad they just see me
like
repping the garden it's very bizarre but
it was fun again it just brings this
novelty
to to that experience and i i'll always
look back at lockdown and there's these
two things
climbing everest and running a marathon
in my garden that i would never have
done before if it wasn't for the
restrictions so sometimes a restriction
can
actually give us creativity the limits
can actually
enable us to have more creativity
because we have to work around
certain things yeah that's a really
really good insight i learned this from
a guy called jack butcher who is a
graphic designer he does visualize value
and the paradox of choice is that when
there's
too many variables for you to play
around with you actually don't end up
doing any genuine creativity because you
just get lost in the choice making from
other bits and pieces
so one of the things that he chose to do
all of his images are a black background
with white
geometric shapes on them and a very
simple font so he never has to choose
colors or style or font or any of that
stuff
so that's a forcing function that means
okay if i want this image to look
different to the last image
it needs to creatively at its
fundamental essence it needs to be
different
and this is what everybody gets caught
up in right like people will spend
six weeks debating over what shade of
blue their company logo should be
but they've only spent two weeks
actually developing and researching the
product and testing out with their
friends or whatever
so yeah restricting the choices on a
thing that you know doesn't matter
i use the same intro music every single
time for this podcast i haven't updated
the the
main album artwork like the image
from three and a half years ago even
though it's if anyone actually wants to
go and look it's slightly off-center
so it doesn't actually look the same but
i'm like look like no one's coming
for the [ __ ] album artwork they're
coming for the experience of listening
to the podcast
like rogan's got like all sorts of
different quirks and stuff on his show
that it's just like well look it doesn't
like is it fundamental to the way that
the show runs no
the same thing with this like reduce
down the choices reduce the restriction
increase the restrictions that you have
and actually okay these are the
parameters that you're working with now
what can you do
yeah absolutely it's a nice way of um
thinking about things and
you can definitely use that when you're
coming up with challenges and
one of the things i always like to
encourage people to do is figure out
how they could challenge themselves and
how they could leave their comfort zones
because obviously the things that i do
are not going to challenge everyone and
they for some people they might be
too ridiculous for other people they're
too easy
um so i think it's it's trying to be
creative trying to come up with
fun ideas and and not having you know
not
having those self-imposed limits that
stop us from
you know discovering something
interesting and
um yeah exciting how much spillover have
you seen
from these acute periods
of discomfort exposure to the more
general ambient uh
sensation that you have day to day oh
yeah completely
it completely changes that firstly it
makes me aware of it
um when i'm feeling uncomfortable for
when life makes you uncomfortable for
whatever
challenge you have to face you know
there's two types of challenges there's
the ones that you choose and the ones
that are forced onto you
so i think by practicing ones and
selecting
different challenges it helps me to
figure out what i can use when life
throws curveballs and life constantly
throws curveballs so i can feel
that my mindset has definitely changed
so for instance about three months ago
i fell off a climb and really badly
injured my ankle and it's still
not properly healed it was a bad strain
or sprain um and
it's just it's a very simple kind of
level of discomfort when i put my foot
down it hurts but
i think my attitude towards it is
completely different from how it would
have been in the past
i can look for the lesson and i can
kind of see it as something that well
there's no point in me complaining about
it
i need to focus on the solution and
there's lots of lessons that i've taken
from
all of these different concepts that
i've been studying that i can directly
apply to
problems that crop up in life that's
what i mean i'm not perfect at it i have
to say like i do i
i'm not gonna put my hands up i'm not
joking willing not yet
oh no not yet it's um but it's
it's it's just it's so interesting
because get comfortable being
uncomfortable is a term that's used a
lot in crossfit and that's my
one of my sports of choice over the last
few years
but i have a real problem with people in
crossfit that use that
term because what they mean is get
comfortable being uncomfortable
and then in brackets afterwards within a
domain that i get to choose
so the difference i'm so glad that you
brought it up to say the difference
between
the elected and the unelected or the the
ones that you choose and the ones that
are forced upon you
like that's so important because
if all that you're doing let's say that
in some world you were able to control
all of the different
um actions that occurred and all that
you were doing
was getting yourself better at being
uncomfortable in situations in future
that you were going to choose to be
uncomfortable in it's kind of pointless
it's like look i'm not making myself
more robust for anything other than
challenges that i want to do
the whole point is to prepare yourself
for when the catastrophe occurs
for when the family member passes away
and it's chaos and you need to give the
eulogy and you're terrified of public
speaking
for when pick your piece of
chaos in life but the weird thing
with this is that by its very nature by
definition
the forced upon you challenges are the
ones that you can't choose
like i mean you could have chosen to
throw yourself off
the the cliff or whatever but i think
that's probably probably a little bit
rich
yeah you've taken it too far like if
you're throwing yourself off cliffs
you're taking it too far
um but you know i mean like it's it's
you need to do the stuff
work within your um
domains of choice to be ready for the
times when you're ripped out of that
yeah and that's really been the whole
point of this whole project for me
is training for life and that's why i
think the variety is important because
for people who are very athletic just
seeking out athletic challenges
isn't necessarily going to give you that
that kind of
broad that the broadness that you need
because a lot of these things are mental
so it's it's trying to really get into
your
psyche and figure out what's going to
push you and just exploring it because
it can be little things and it's it's
just looking for all these different
places and the more you do it the more
you feel prepared for whatever chaos is
around the corner because that's the one
thing we can guarantee that life is
going to
keep throwing challenges at us so it
makes sense to prepare
in fact it it's crazy not to
benjamin thank you so much for coming on
people want to check out your stuff
where should they go
um so very active on instagram um the
handle is at do things that challenge
you
um i'm on twitter at i am ben aldridge
website benaldridge.com and there's a
newsletter there
and yeah that's probably that's it
that's a good place to come and come and
say hi
i love it cheers man thanks so much
great to chat
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here
for a selection of the best clips from
the podcast over the last few months
and don't forget to subscribe makes me
very happy indeed
peace